um but really it's this they might come
in six to seven minutes but a lot can
happen in six to seven minutes and so
why don't we I'm going to refrain from
making any jokes about that because I
think they'd be in poor taste but you
make a very valid implied one that is
true that is it's both a joke and a
reality yeah you know everything that
matters in that scenario is gonna happen
before the cops get there nine times out
of ten and you were there was a great
New York Times piece and you wrote in it
this is a personal thing for you you
grew up in a single-mother household you
you had been assaulted you this is this
isn't just some political philosophy
conversation this is something that you
can really speak about as a as an
individual absolutely and also the fact
that at that point when I was making
those decisions of man I do want to
fight for this issue because you know it
is not even a political issue because I
dealt with it but I was coming from the
left at that point I was brand-new I I
think I'm gonna think at that time I
made a decision that I realized you know
what I do have conservative values and
that's why I realize I can strongly you
know go to the point that it is not a
political issue it really is me American
I should it is a human rights issue it
really is but particularly with women
and the differences that science has
proven over and over again but really
when it's not even just about that I
mean you're you I mean yeah or coming
against someone who is a male or woman
who has a firearm that person is gonna
win you know regardless of how big you
are you're male or not no I am very much
so it is true physically intimidate a
lot of attackers but now even despite
all those great qualities you know it's
it's still bad for you at that point to
have something that's gonna be equalizer
so I think that's important do you think
there's a racial component of this to
you know specifically toward arming
young black women who are say
disproportionately more likely to be
assaulted or do you think there is a
racial inequality on this issue I think
I mean this that's I've been showing
that black women and black women are the
fastest-growing demographic
who are becoming gun owners and so I
think they are seeing that whether it's
a political issue and that's a lot of
people they they hate the fact that you
know black women are now becoming gun
owners and so they twist it into well
it's because the less what happened to
last year oh it's Trump you know racism
and it's just spinning is this good you
know just blown up and that's why our
gun now yeah to protect against Trump
Trump and the racism that's you know
just prevalent now it doesn't kind of it
no and I always said they talked to me
about that they'll interview me about
that and be like no it's been happening
the last few years before we even knew
about Trump so I'm not gonna do with
that for me I think it's also has to do
with the rise of women in general you
know a lot more about you talk about
governance and a lot more of us are you
know will fire a buyer self at home a
lot of us are still pursuing an
education longer maybe you know that
transition from leaving a household
where your father figure is there and
then having it where your spouse is
there there's a bigger gap there so a
lot more women feel that they have to
take safety into their own hands and I
actually was also think that's just an
extension of you know if you want to
bring with them in this aspect of it the
feminist movement is an extension of
that independence and so black women
especially are in these areas that tend
to be you know sisters statistically
more dangerous and they're by themselves
and so I hear all the time with other
women with their daughters and they're
like I want to buy his gun kind of went
protect my daughter I want to know how
to use it I want to protect myself so I
think that's really what it's about
that's the single woman